hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
approaches for rapid genomic
surveillance to identify sars kobe 2
variants
i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by diasporin molecular
to learn more visit them at
molecular.diasauring.com
now we want to encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you might have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send all questions will be
answered via email
following the broadcast you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you ever having any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker dr
donna wolk
division director of molecular and
microbial
diagnostics and development from the
department of
laboratory medicine at geisinger for a
complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the presenter information
top of your screen dr wilk welcome you
may now
begin your presentation
hello i'd like to welcome the
participants to the webinar today
my name is donna wolk i'm the division
director for molecular microbial
diagnostics at geisinger
diagnostic medicine institute i'll be
talking to you today about the potential
impact of sars kobe 2 variants on our
laboratory testing
by way of a little background of where i
work and live
the diagnostic medicine institute is in
danville pennsylvania
we have 125 clia certified sites we have
42
couriers and about 1100 employees and
about 15 million tests
annually and this is the region that we
cover
in central northeast pennsylvania so
that is
that's the perspective i'll have because
i
i work here the objectives today are to
review the common molecular viral
targets used for patient
testing um of the sars cov2 virus
and list the emergency use authorization
methods
discuss the potential of solarus cov2 on
variants on the eua test method and
describe different
methods for variant detection so first
of all let's start with what is a sars
cov2 variant and why should i worry
about it
well it does have implications for
public health the diagnostic industry
and bio industry
and the clinical diagnostic laboratory
the genes within the sars cov2
um are listed here in in the picture
the orf genes spike envelope matrix and
nucleocapsid
the diagnostic tests we use in the
clinical laboratory generally have
more than one gene target and that's for
redundancy
and to protect itself from to protect
the test
from impact of mutations
and what is a mutation just kind of a
little
uh refresher for everyone a mutation can
be a substitution
where in one or more nucleic acids are
interchanged
switched it can be an insertion
where one or more nucleic acids are
inserted
into the viral genome it can be a
deletion where they're taken away
it can be a recombination where pieces
will
switch sections of the viral
genome are exchanged and the mutation
rate is a term we use
to characterize the speed in which the
virus mutates
this is a picture of a mutation wheel
that we use to convert
common mutations in the nucleic acid
form
into associated protein changes now why
is that important just for your general
understanding of how the mutants are
identified
if you're doing ngs in any kind of
manner
you're going to need to be able to
switch between the nucleic acid
and the uh amino acid
so in this case you know we l452r
would recognize the genetic change here
in the center
that causes leucine to become arginine
the n501y which is a common mutation
flips asparagine to tyrosine
and so forth so this is a way that you
can
look at the names that the cdc and the
who
give to the mutations they're often
based on
one or more of these nomenclature
standards
so this slide describes the the four
most common methods used to identify
sars cov2 in clinical specimens we have
rtpcr
which is reverse transcriptase pcr it is
a thermal cycling process
and can be manual or automated and
typically
it is in a real-time
fluorescently tagged type of method
the tma transcription mediated
amplification is isothermal and also
automated and takes advantage of
fluorescent
fluorescence in the form of rlu's or
relative light
units the rt lamp is loop-mediated
amplification for rna viruses it is
isothermal
it can be manual or semi-automated and
then the crispr
or crispr cast as some people call it
the clustered regularly interspersed
short palindromic repeats
is manual or semi-automated also
isothermal
why do we use the clinical uh diagnostic
testing and how
how has that expanded during the
pandemic
we all have recently
taken our clinical and diagnostic
testing and
can you know confined it to symptomatic
testing
but we're now also involved in
surveillance testing
for health related events checking for
viral shedding
looking for shedding when people go
from the hospital to long-term care and
in some cases non-health care related
surveillance for schools businesses
teams and pre-travel
so it's no longer our world is no longer
respiratory symptoms defined for sars
cov2
we're also involved in contact testing
so when the department of health will
have
exposures that they are known exposures
we can
participate in contact testing and
following up
and and the public health laboratories
as well as us
uh will be involved in epidemiological
testing
to to do sort of blind surveillance on
the population
that is mostly a public health
surveillance
issue but sometimes clinical
laboratories do get involved in research
as well now in our testing
menus we need to understand that we need
to continue
to be vigilant for strain variation that
could
impact our test performance so we know
that there's many thousands of sars cov2
variants
and the subtypes are categorized for us
into larger groups sometimes called
lineages
clads variant groupings
and the two main ways to do that are in
silico testing
where the laboratory or the assay
designer will monitor known mutations
and check it against the primary probe
regions of their
testing and make sure there's no problem
with the binding and the primers or
probes
and then we have in vitro testing where
actual clinical
uh samples with known strain variants
are tested
or or unknown strain variants are tested
to
identify if if those are um
meeting the criteria for a variant for
sars kovi ii
now there's a lot of surveillance going
on in the united states and around the
globe for the viral mutations
in the united states about six to seven
percent
of the virus isolates are being
sequenced
the virus mutates at a rate of about two
mutations per month
and they are mostly single nucleotide
and the cdc puts out a
bar graph that shows the recent variance
and the changes in them
and so you can see here the b.1.1.7
that gained in popularity and and these
are um
available usually on the state and
federal public health websites
this is a on the right is a map of the
vaccination rate so right now
you know we're fighting the vaccination
rate
hoping it will become higher so these
variants
don't get out of control the only way to
stop the variants
is to get people vaccinated but there's
still a relatively low vaccination rate
in certain states in certain
geographical pockets and that is why we
have to continue
to be vigilant for the viral
mutations cdc classifies the variants
and the mutations into
three major categories um we've talked
about
all the mutations thousands of them that
have no
known consequence and we won't we won't
belabor that any further
but there is um a variance of interest a
variant concern
and a variant of high consequence all
three
of the variant categories show reduced
uh effectiveness to the monoclonal
antibody combinations for therapy
and the convalescent and post
vaccination serum
the variant of concern is is more severe
or
more of a of a worry than the variant of
interest it also has
increased transmission increased
severity
as does the variant of high consequence
and the demonstrated failure of diagnose
diagnostics so here we come into the
range where we are being impacted in the
clinical laboratory
and then a variant of high concern
there's really none of these yet
but it would be called if there was
reduced effectiveness
to any of the therapeutics and
medications that are there or miss with
the vaccine
so these are examples of the sars-kov2
nomenclature
and the associated protein changes or
amino acid changes
and then up top you'll see
the abbreviations for variance of
concern or variants of interest the voi
so the alpha variance of b1
b.1.1.7 origin
originated in the uk and
these are the amino acid changes that
you would see
in that particular variant the
the beta variant is the b.1.351 the
south african
similar and other changes there
these are these are describing some of
the common amino acids and how they're
characterized but it's
it's the whole sequence that will
actually tell you
uh specifically
and confirm that you have these variants
in your population
then we have the gamma variant the delta
variant the epsilon zeta
eta iota and kappa so many of these
are you'll see some of them are listed
more than twice the one that's
originated in brazil has the p1 and the
p2
and they are named differently because
of their genetic dissimilarity
so here you have the who nomenclature
which is the greek you have the next
strain nomenclature
which is the amino acid then you have
the pangolina
which is commonly used to identify those
strains so this
this will give you a little bit of a
help when you're trying to sort out
which variants they're talking about
it's it's a little complicated because
there's more than one
name for each of these
here are the
these are the variants of concern
and these are the variants of interest
just listed for you so that you know
what they are
um the p1 the b.1427 and 429
the delta variant which we hear about in
the news from
india the beta and the alpha
and only the alpha the bu.1.1.7
originating in the uk has a gene dropout
that actually will cause
a failure of some of the targets but it
doesn't cause failure in all of the
targets so it's not
still considered an assay that has to be
discarded it can it can still be used
because there's three targets and
some of the assays that that use this
particular target
here's the the three main nomenclatures
that are used uh when you're sequencing
viruses and they're naming viruses the
gif aid
is the global initiative on sharing all
influenza data
and it has been adapted for covid
sarskovy ii it designates eight
global clades the next strain has 11
major clades and that is more for
real-time tracking
and then the pangolin phylogenetic
assessment of named global outbreak
lineages
this is the one that you'll see that
we've been talking about the b.1.1.7
and others so those are the major
lineage
lineage definers and they're all
different
genomic databases and they all have
different
nomenclature namings
public health institutes can also
institute their own nomenclature
changes to track specific variances and
in this country in the united states
the center for disease control has
something called a microbe trace
where they can map person-to-person
contacts and pathogen or pathogen
genetic distance and person-to-person
exposures
you'll see maps like this on the news
or if you search the wh site or the next
strain site and it will give you the
proportion
of different variants that are
present in different countries across
the globe and will give you the
phylogenetic tree
which tells you the relatedness of the
viruses the shorter the arms
the more related the viruses are the
longer
the arms the more unrelated they are
and this is a cdc website
that they will let you sign up for when
they have
new information you can sign up to this
and get emails
about the epidemiology of sars kobe 2.
so what is the diagnostic and
bioindustry surveillance approach
well actually you know many many
companies and
and many laboratories do both in
in silico and in in vitro
and the fda also monitors the genomic
changes in silico
and this is their website for evaluating
the viral
mutations and the impact on coded tests
so i would check in with this often
because
you know your if if there are other
variants that
impact your tests they will be posted
here
bio industry generally will at first do
an in silico assessment
and this is on the table on the right
just shows
a variety of different manufacturers and
what their choice
of genes are you can see some have three
some have one
and most have two so
this is where the industry really helps
the clinical laboratories actively
monitor
the genetic reports and they will
announce any information that impacts
their
the laboratory surveillance approach is
in silico if you've designed your own
primers and in vitro
for clinical samples that have unusual
characteristics and
you know people are asking well
how do we pay for this what what do why
do we need to do this do we need to do
it at
all um so this is this is one algorithm
that we've defined
that was designed to try to enrich for
us the likelihood of us finding variants
in our population
the concepts to consider when you're
when you're trying to
do next generation sequencing or send to
a reference laboratory for
ngs or use a multiplex for
strain identification is the cost
the expected turnaround time the needs
of your local epidemiology
which populations to test and
the whether or not to use the ngs or the
rtpcr multiplex panels for variant
detection
so in our hospital we look at any kind
of
potential outbreaks that might be
occurring among
people who are fully vaccinated
we look at people in the icu who
are fully vaccinated luckily we haven't
had any outbreaks
in a fully vaccinated population yet
but we also monitor for unusual test
results
and then we we form an interdisciplinary
review group with
laboratory infectious disease and
infection prevention to
uh determine whether this needs to be
investigated and then the laboratory
will decide
the best approach whether to investigate
the sample on another platform
to perform the multiplex target assays
or
the full ngs
now this so this is a pie chart of what
we saw this last
april of 2021 and when we
did just a simple
20 sample screen by ngs
and we know that in april
the year passed we were 100 percent wild
type which is up here with the pango a
and b
and now this april we've gone from
twenty percent
uh we've gone down to twenty percent
wild type and eighty percent
um variance of some kind
two are not variants of interest or
concern
but we were able to identify a
proportion 40 percent of the b
1.1.7 20 of the b1526
and 6 of the b142c
so we we were able to confirm for our
epidemiologists that we have these
variants of concern in our population
and we will likely just perform
these surveillance from time to time
to be monitoring for the delta variant
and such and and if we have any kind of
unusual events we will also also
do that there's no diagnostic
reimbursement yet
so the testing is really for outbreak
investigation only
you can screen for these variants with
the multiplex rtpcr with or without mass
spectrometry
the rt pcr multiplex direct from sample
and ngs when you're doing considerations
for
banking or testing your samples you may
want to consider
rna preservatives using dedicated
pipettes and supplies having an rnas
free zone
and extraction and then freezing perhaps
with a
with a protectant and and just a tip
there if you're
if you're freezing a high density
isolate you can fill the dead space in
in the top of the tube with with liquid
and probably still have enough
to keep a cycle threshold that's
reasonable depends on your ct value
but that dead space can cause water
hydrolysis over time so just be careful
of that
now the diagnostic methods for
the variant testing are to to suspect
there's a variant confirm
and perform active surveillance these
are the commercially available multiplex
rtpcr methods
the kovat kobas sarsko 2 variant set
the simplex sars kobe 2 variant direct
the bio rad kovi 2 variant sa
the all plex sars kovi 2 variant which
is ce ibd
the bio search value panels and the
agena
mass array sars cov2 variant panel which
is
all the others are ruo
and finally the two platforms for
next-gen sequencing
which is used for research or
epidemiology is the thermo fisher iron
torrent
or the illumina kovidzique there are
other methods these are the two most
common
and they each have research panels
that allow you to identify
the full genome sequence of interest
for the sars cov2 virus
so in conclusion we talked about the
common molecular targets
used in testing patient samples the
major eeua
methods the potential impact of the
variants on
our eoa test methods and different
methods for variant detection
i thank you very much for your attention
and have a great day
thank you dr wolf for that informative
presentation i'd also like to thank the
lab roots and our sponsor dia soren for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time to answer
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast will be viewed
on demand lab routes will alert you via
email
when it's available for replay we can
encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone bye